量子情報と計算の理解へようこそ。俺はJohn Watusで、IBMの教育担当テクニカルディレクターだ
Quantum。これはシリーズの第14レッスンで、量子エラーに関する第4ユニットの第2レッスンだ
訂正。前回のレッスンでは、量子エラー訂正を初めて見た。9 qubit Shorコードも含めて、それが
量子エラー訂正が理論上可能だと示している。エラーの離散化についても議論した。それによって
qubit上の任意の量子エラーを、ビットフリップと位相への射影によって効果的に訂正できる
フリップだ。このレッスンではスタビライザー形式主義について議論する。これは数学的ツールで、それを通じて
スタビライザーコードとして知られる広範なクラスの量子エラー訂正コードを指定・解析できる。これには9 qubit Shorが含まれる
コード、そして他の多くの例も含まれる。実世界の量子に遥かに適していそうなコードも含めてだ
コンピューティングデバイスにとって、ShorコードよりもNだ。すべての量子エラー訂正コードがスタビライザーコードというわけではないが、多くはそうだ
このシリーズで見るすべての例も含めてだ。確かに興味深くて潜在的に有用な量子エラーも存在する
スタビライザーコードではない訂正コードもあるが、それらはかなり複雑になりがちで、いずれにせよ
スタビライザー形式主義が量子エラー訂正の基盤の礎石であることは疑いなく、俺たちは
ユニットの残りの部分でそれに大きく依存する。ここでレッスンの簡単な概要を示す。まずPolyの短い議論から始める
行列とPolyの行列のテンソル積、これらはqubit上の演算と
qubitの測定の両方を表せる。説明するようにこの文脈では観測量と呼ぶことが多い。それから振り返って
繰り返しコードをもう一度見る。Poly演算と観測量でそれをどう記述できるかを見て、それが両方を情報として与え
スタビライザーコードの一般的な議論に繋がる。いくつかの例も含めて、スタビライザーの基本的な性質も
コードと、エンコード、エラー検出、エラー訂正という基本タスクの実行方法も。
レッスンをPoly演算の簡単な議論から始めよう。主に
スタビライザー形式主義の舞台設定のためだが、いくつかの重要な事実を観察して基本的な用語を確立するためでもある。まずPolyの
行列だ。2x2の単位行列と、3つの非単位Poly行列も含まれる。それらを
このシリーズの残りでは大文字X、Y、Zで表す。これら4つの行列はすべてユニタリーかつエルミートで、
qubit上の演算と同定できる。意図的に実行する演算とエラーの両方として、
前回のレッスンで議論した通りだ。非単位Poly行列X、Y、ZはそれぞれEとアンチコミュートする
つまりXYは-1 * YXに等しい。XZはマイナスZXに等しく、YZは等しい
マイナスZYに。掛け算をすることでこれらの関係を簡単に確認できる。これらのアンチ交換
関係は非常にシンプルだが、スタビライザー形式主義その他において極めて重要で、特に
見ていくように、積の中で2つの異なる非単位Poly行列の順序を交換した時に現れるこのマイナス符号は、正確に
スタビライザー形式主義におけるエラー検出に対応する。ここに掲載された掛け算のルールもある。それぞれの
Poly行列は自身の逆元で、これはユニタリーかつエルミートであるという事実と整合している。そして2つの異なる非単位
Poly行列を掛け合わせると、常にプラスかマイナスのI倍の残りの非単位が得られる
Poly行列だ。特にグローバル位相を無視すると、YはX掛けるZと同等で、これがxとzのエラーに注目する理由を説明している
量子エラー訂正において。Xはビットフリップを表し、Zは位相フリップを表す。だからグローバル位相を無視するとyは
同じ qubit上でこれら両方のエラーが発生していることを表す。これら4つの行列はすべて
1つのqubit上の演算、エラー、またはエラーがないことを表す。しかしそれらをテンソルで合わせると便利なことが多い
複数のqubit上で演算やエラーを実行するためだ。用語として、N qubit Poly
演算と言う時は、例として示されているようなn個のPoly行列のテンソル積を意味する
グローバル位相がある場合にもPoly演算という用語を使うことは一般的だが、できるだけシンプルにするため
Poly演算という用語はPoly行列のテンソル積を意味するとする。N qubit Poly
演算の重みとは、テンソル積における非単位Poly行列の数だ。例えばn重テンソル
2x2単位行列自身との積は重み0のPoly演算だ。2つのPolyX
行列と大量の単位行列のテンソル積は重み2、など。直感的に言うと、NのPoly演算の重みは
qubit Poly演算が非自明に作用するqubitの数で、量子エラー訂正コードが
ある重みまでのPoly演算で表されるエラーを検出・訂正できるように設計されているのが典型的だ。
Poly演算についてはさまざまな観点で考えられる。量子Gateによって意図的に行われる演算としてもそうだし、
エラーとしてもだ。またPoly演算が測定を記述できることもまもなく見る。場合によっては有用なことがある
代数的な意味でPolyを特定の集合の生成元として考えること。群論に馴染みがあれば
わかるかもしれない。群論に馴染みがなくても大丈夫だ。このレッスンには本質的ではない
でも量子エラー訂正をより深く研究したいなら、いくらかの基本的な群論が
それに非常に役立つとわかるかもしれない。ともかく、P1からPRがN qubit Poly演算だとしよう
P1はN qubit Poly演算、P2もN qubit Poly演算、などだ。
P1からPRで生成される集合とは、これらの行列を掛け合わせることで得られるすべての行列の集合で、
任意の組み合わせで任意の順序、それぞれを何度でも使える。すぐにいくつかの例を見る
が、まずこの集合を表す記法に触れよう。P1からPRで生成される集合、
P1からPRをコンマで区切って山括弧の中に入れる。直接記法と混同しやすそうに見えるかもしれない
が、一般的にそうはならない。これが群論における伝統的な記法だ。
X、Y、Zで生成される集合の例を示す。この例ではnは1に等しい、テンソル積がないので
3つすべての非単位Poly行列を生成元として取っている。実は
これら3つの行列を含む積を作ることで16個の行列が生成される。これは
先ほど見た掛け算のルールで推論できる。具体的にはX、Y、Zとそして単位行列も当然得られる
実際にこれら4つの行列にI、1、マイナスIを掛けたものも得られる、それが
この集合はパウリ群として一般に知られている。xとzだけで生成される集合も考えられる
そうするとパウリ群の半分が得られる
最後の例として、少なくとも今のところは、X tensor xとz tensor Zで生成される集合を考えてみよう。つまりnは
この場合2に等しく、X tensor xとz tensor Zという事実から今回はたった四つの要素しか得られない
互いに可換であるということだ。パウリ行列とn qubit パウリ演算はより一般的に
ユニタリ演算を記述する。エラーであれ意図的なものであれ、しかし同時に
測定も記述する。より正確には、三つの非恒等パウリ行列から始めて、それぞれに対応するものを関連付けられる
行列を固有値と固有ベクトルで定義された射影測定と結びつける。画面上に
これらの行列のスペクトル分解が示されており、これを明確にするのに役立つ。本質的にはX
測定、Y測定、またはZ測定と言うとき、射影によって定義された射影測定を意味する
これらの行列の固有空間への射影であり、一般的に固有値を対応する
測定結果として考える。例えばX測定は、プラスに関する測定だ
qubitのマイナス基底、あるいは代わりにket プラス bra プラスとkの射影を含む集合で記述できる
マイナス bra マイナスだ。Z測定は一方で標準基底
測定に他ならない。もっとも先ほど言ったように、固有値を測定結果と同一視することもある。そうすると
結果はそれぞれ0と1ではなくプラスとマイナス1となる。実際には
任意のエルミート行列に対してもこれと同様のことができ、この状況ではパウリに対してobservableという用語が一般的に使われる
行列とn qubitパウリ演算に対してより一般的には、位相推定を使って非破壊的にこうした測定を実行できる
この図が明確であることを確認するために、ここでは上のqubitを非破壊的に測定している
一方、下のqubitは常にプラス状態、つまり言い換えれば零状態にHadamardを適用した状態に初期化される
なぜなら位相推定はそのように機能するからだ。固有値が
この場合プラス1とマイナス1だけなので、必要な制御qubitは一つだけだ。図の下のqubitがそれだ
それ以上は無駄になる。なぜなら精度は1ビットしかないからだ。固有値は
プラス1かマイナス1かのどちらかで、測定はこのままでも完璧だ。この測定の結果
つまりcircuit内の標準基底測定は、プラス1の固有値結果に対してゼロになる
X observableの場合はプラス状態に対応し、マイナス1の固有値に対して結果は1となる
またはこの場合のマイナス状態だ。今述べたことはすべてn qubitパウリ演算に自然に拡張される
observableについて考えるとき、固有ベクトルの基底で測定するのではなく固有値を測定していることを念頭に置く必要がある
固有ベクトルの基底で測定するのではない。例えば二つの
qubitパウリ演算 Z tensor Z を考えよう。やはりプラス1とマイナス1の二つの固有値があるので
測定は二つの射影で記述される。特に注目すべきは、このobservableに関連付ける測定が
二つのqubitをZ測定つまり標準基底測定で測定することとは異なるという点だ。むしろそれは二つの
結果射影測定であり、射影は対応するすべての固有ベクトルが張る空間への射影だ
二つの固有値プラス1とマイナス1それぞれに対応する。別の考え方として、テンソル積の固有値は
テンソル積を取っている個々の行列の固有値の積になるということだ
例えばマイナス1×マイナス1はプラス1×プラス1と同じなので、この測定は
0 0と1 1を区別しない。例えばΦプラスベル状態をこの測定で測定すると
このobservableで記述されると、固有値プラス1に対応する結果が確実に得られる
そして状態は変化しない。もし標準基底測定を行えば0 0か1 1に収縮するのとは対照的だ
二つのqubitに対して標準基底測定を行った場合と異なる。つまりz tensor z測定は
二つのZ測定を独立に行うこととは別物だが、位相推定を使えばこうした測定を実際に実行できる
先ほどとまったく同じ方法で、一つの制御qubitを使って。circuitの図に示されているように
Z tensor Zの代わりに任意のn qubitパウリ演算に一般化できる。パウリZ行列だけの場合
circuitをこのように簡略化できる。これが示しているのは、測定を定義する射影からも明らかだが
二つのqubitに対してz tensor Z測定を行うことはそのパリティを測定することと同等だということだ
標準基底で考えると。これは任意の数のパウリZ行列のテンソル積に一般化される
次に3ビット繰り返しコードをもう一度見てみよう。今度はパウリの観点から表現する
これが最初のシンプルなスタビライザーコードの例となる。これをどう一般化するかはすぐに議論するが
まずこのシンプルなケースでどのように機能するか見ておくと有益だ。3ビット繰り返しコードを
qubitに適用すると、qubit状態アルファ0プラスベータ1を、アルファ000プラスベータ111としてエンコードする
便宜上この三qubitエンコーディングをサイと呼ぶ。定義上sは有効な三qubit
qubit状態のエンコーディングだが、これを確認したければ次の二つの式が真であることを確認すれば十分だ
最初の式はsの左端二つのqubitにZ演算を適用してもsに何も変化がないということを示す。つまり
sはZ tensor Z tensor Identityつまり略してZZ Identityの固有ベクトルであり固有値1を持つ。二番目の
式も同様だが、Z演算が右端二つのqubitに適用される点が異なる。sを
標準基底状態の線形結合として考えると、最初の式はゼロでない係数を持つのは標準基底状態のうち
左端二ビットが偶数パリティを持つ、つまり等しいものだけだということを意味する。二番目の式は
右端二ビットが偶数パリティを持つ標準基底状態に対してのみゼロでない係数が存在することを意味する。別の考え方として
これら二つのパウリ演算をobservableとして見ることだ。この二つのobservableをさっき述べた
簡略化されたcircuitを使って測定すると、プラス1の固有値に対応する測定結果が確実に得られる
sが両方のobservableの固有ベクトルであり固有値1を持つからだ。しかしこの簡略化されたcombined
観測量を独立に測定するためのcircuitは、3ビット
繰り返し符号のパリティチェックcircuitに他ならない。つまり、2つの方程式を合わせると、パリティチェックcircuitが0 0を出力することと同値だとわかる。
これはエラーが検出されなかったことを示すシンドロームだ。3 qubitのパウリ演算、
ZZ恒等式と恒等式ZZは、この符号のstabilizer generatorと呼ばれる。符号のstabilizerは、
stabilizer generatorから生成される集合だ。この集合、stabilizerは根本的に重要な数学的
対象であり、レッスンが進むにつれてこの符号との関係についてさらに詳しく見ていく。今は
generatorの選び方が別にもあり得ることを指摘しておこう。例えば、Z恒等式Zをどちらかの
generatorの代わりに選んでも、符号もstabilizerも全く同じになる。次に、パウリ
演算間の相互作用や関係に注目しながら、3ビット繰り返し符号のビット反転
検出を考える。具体的にはstabilizer generatorとエラー自体だ。3ビット繰り返し符号でqubitを符号化し、
左端のqubitにビット反転エラーが発生したとしよう。これにより、状態Ψは
左端のqubitへのX演算、つまりXエラーの作用に従って変換される。すでに知っている通り、このエラーは
3ビット繰り返し符号のパリティチェックを実行することで検出できる。同等に、
stabilizer generatorを観測量として扱い、非破壊的に符号化を測定することもできる。まず最初の
stabilizer generatorで何が起きるか見てみよう。状態はXエラーの影響を受けており、
observableとしてのstabilizer generatorの測定がこのエラーにどう影響されるかを理解したい。XとZは反交換するが、
恒等行列とは全て交換する。よって、ZZ恒等式はX恒等式
恒等式と反交換する。つまり順序を入れ替えるとマイナス符号が付く。またZZ恒等式はSに何もしない、
なぜならSはqubitの有効な符号化であり、有効な符号化は常に両方のstabilizer generatorの+1固有ベクトルだからだ。
すると−X恒等式恒等式をSに適用した形が残る。したがってX恒等式恒等式をSに適用したものは、
ZZ恒等式の固有値−1の固有ベクトルだ。同様のことが
2番目のstabilizer generatorでもできる。ただし今回はエラーがstabilizer generatorと交換するため、
破損した状態はstabilizer generatorの固有ベクトルのままだが、今度は固有値が正の
1になる。つまり破損した状態は両方のstabilizer generatorの固有ベクトルであり、固有値が+1か
−1かは、エラーが各stabilizer generatorと交換するか反交換するかで決まる。最初の
stabilizer generatorについてはエラーと反交換し、2番目については交換する。必ず一方か他方になる、なぜなら任意の2つの
パウリ演算は交換するか反交換するかのどちらかだからだ。一方、実際の状態Ψはあまり重要な
役割を果たさない。stabilizer generatorがこの状態に自明に作用するという事実を除けば。だから、エラーの
検出を考えるとき、特定の符号化状態は気にする必要がない。重要なのはエラーが各stabilizer generatorと交換するか反交換するかだ。
では、各stabilizer generatorに1行、各エラーに1列の表を作ろう。
ここでは単一ビット反転に対応するエラーのみを含めた。
エラーなし（恒等式を3回テンソル積したもので示される）も含める。必要なら他のエラーの列も追加できる。
今はこれらのエラーだけに注目しよう。表の各エントリは+1か−1で、
エラーとstabilizer generatorが交換するか反交換するかによって決まる。表の各エラーについて、
対応する列を見ると、そのエラーが任意の符号化を各stabilizer generatorの+1か−1の固有
ベクトルにどう変換するかがわかる。これらの列は、stabilizer generatorを
observableとして非破壊的に測定することと同値なパリティチェックから得られるシンドロームに正確に対応する。
もちろん表のエントリは+1と−1であり、それぞれ0と1ではない。
好みに応じて、+1と−1の列ではなく対応する2進文字列としてシンドロームを考えてもよいが、
直接の対応がある。シンドロームと固有値の対応をより明確に直接示すために、
これらの+1と−1のベクトルを前と同様にシンドロームと呼ぶことにする。シンドロームは
発生したエラーについて何かを教えてくれる。特に、これら4つの可能なエラーのうち1つが
発生したとわかっているなら、シンドロームはどれが発生したかを示す。そして再びエラーを適用することで修正できる。
次に、シンドロームについてもう少し述べる。特にその
代数的な側面を詳しく見ていこう。符号化は3 qubit状態なので、8次元複素ベクトル空間の単位ベクトルだ。
4つの可能なシンドロームがこの8次元空間を
4つの2次元部分空間に分割する。つまり、これらの部分空間のいずれかにあるベクトルは常に同じシンドロームを与える。
詳細には、この図が8次元空間の分割を示している。
各stabilizer generatorが空間を同次元の2つの部分空間に分割する。つまり+1固有ベクトルの空間と
−1固有ベクトルの空間だ。例えば、ZZ恒等式の+1固有ベクトルは、左端2ビットが偶数パリティの標準基底状態の線形結合であり、
−1固有ベクトルは左端2ビットが奇数パリティの標準基底状態の線形結合だ。状況はもう一方の
stabilizer generatorでも同様だが、
左端2ビットではなく右端2ビットになる。この4つの部分空間は簡単に
記述できる。これは非常に単純な符号だからだ。特に、シンドローム+1 +1に対応する部分空間は
|000⟩と|111⟩で張られる空間、つまり有効な
符号化の空間であり、これが符号空間と呼ばれる。一般に、空間は対応する正方形に示された標準基底状態で張られるが、
必ずしも明確に見えるわけではない。シンドロームは
また、発生し得るパウリエラーを表す全ての3 qubitパウリ演算を、4つの等サイズの集合に分割する。
分割の基準はそのエラーが引き起こすシンドロームだ。例えば、任意のパウリ演算のうち
両方のstabilizer generatorと交換するものはシンドローム+1 +1を引き起こす。64通りの3 qubit
パウリ演算のうち、この分類に属するものはちょうど16個あり、画面に表示されている3つもその中に含まれる。残り3つのシンドロームについても同様だ。
シンドロームが状態空間をどちらも分割するというのは直感的には分からないが、これは事実で、
エンコーディングが存在する状態空間と、空間内のすべてのポーリ演算子を等しいサイズの部分に分割するというこの基本的な性質は、
スタビライザーコード全般において成り立つ。これについては間もなく正確に定義するが、今のところはほぼ余談だ。
ただ、両方のstabilizerジェネレーターと可換なポーリ演算子、言い換えれば
シンドロームが+1, +1になるが、stabilizerの要素に比例しないポーリ演算子は、ちょうど
エンコードした論理qubitに対する単一qubitポーリ演算子のように振る舞う。例えば、XXXは
両方のstabilizerジェネレーターと可換だが、stabilizerのどの要素にも比例しない。そして少し考えれば分かるように、
このcodeにおいてこの演算がエンコーディングに与える効果は、
エンコードされた論理qubitに対するX gateと等価だ。これもまたすべてのスタビライザーコードに一般化される。さて、スタビライザー
codeを一般的に定義する時が来た。仕組みとしては、先ほど議論した内容と完全に類似したことを行う。
3ビット繰り返しcodeと同様だが、異なるstabilizerジェネレーターを選ぶ。それをP1
からPRと呼ぶことにする。この説明のためにいうと、これらのstabilizerジェネレーターはすべてn qubitポーリ演算子でなければならない。
nはエンコーディングに使われるqubitの数だ。そして、stabilizerジェネレーターには任意のものを選べるわけではなく、
いくつかの基本的な条件を満たす必要がある。まず、stabilizerジェネレーターはすべて互いに可換でなければならない。
3ビット繰り返しcodeの場合はこれを特に確認しなかったが、ZZ恒等演算子と恒等演算子
ZZは実際に可換だと観察するのは簡単だ。ZはZ自身と可換で、すべてのものが
恒等演算子と可換だからだ。一方、もっと複雑なstabilizerジェネレーターを持つスタビライザーコードでは、
XとZの両方がstabilizerジェネレーターに現れるようなcodeでは、これは確認が必要な重要な条件だ。
この条件が必要な理由の一つの考え方は、stabilizerジェネレーターをオブザーバブルとして扱うということだ。すべてが可換であることを要求することで、
これらの測定を行う順序が結果に
影響しないことを保証している。次に、stabilizerジェネレーターはいわゆる最小生成集合を形成しなければならない。つまり、
どれか一つを取り除くとより小さいstabilizerになるということだ。これを数学的に表現する一つの方法が画面に
示されている。厳密に言えば、この条件はスタビライザーcodeの動作における運用的な意味では本質的なものではない。
また次のレッスンで見るように、非最小生成集合を考えることが有意義な場合もある。しかし
スタビライザーcodeを分析してその性質を説明するために、この条件が成立していると
仮定する。基本的にこの条件は、シンドロームを得るために測定する各オブザーバブルが
起こりうるエラーに関する情報を追加していることを保証し、他のstabilizerジェネレーターのオブザーバブルから容易に
推測できる冗長な結果を出さないようにする。最後に、少なくとも一つの非ゼロベクトルがすべての
stabilizerジェネレーターで固定されなければならない。これはn qubitの恒等演算子に-1を乗じたものが
stabilizerに含まれないことを要求するのと等価だ。直感的ではないが、ポイントは相互に可換なn qubitポーリ演算子の
最小生成集合を選べても、それらのすべての+1固有ベクトルを同時に持つベクトルが
存在しない可能性があるということだ。有効なエンコーディングが存在しないcodeは
面白くないので、そのような可能性は考えたくない。以上がスタビライザーcodeにおけるstabilizerジェネレーターの要件だ。これらの条件を
満たす生成集合があれば、有効なスタビライザーcodeが存在し、その性質を検討できる。
様々な性質を持つ多くの異なるスタビライザーcodeがあるが、それらはすべて特定の基本的な
性質を満たす。それらは3ビット繰り返しcodeですでに観察したものと類似している。
まもなくいくつかの例を見ていくが、その前に、スタビライザーcodeのcode空間とは、N qubit状態空間の部分空間で、
すべてのstabilizerジェネレーターの+1固有ベクトルを同時に持つすべてのベクトルを含むものを指すと述べておく。
これはnqubit状態空間の部分空間で、有効なエンコーディングが存在する場所だ。レッスンが進むにつれてこの部分空間についてさらに述べていく。
では、いくつかのスタビライザーcodeの例を見ていこう。
ここには既に議論した通常の3ビット繰り返しcodeの例がある。前のレッスンで扱った
ビットフリップではなく位相フリップを検出できるcodeの変形版も、スタビライザーcodeとして表現できる。
今回はstabilizerジェネレーターがZZオブザーバブルではなくXXオブザーバブルを測定するので、これらは基本的に
標準基底ではなくプラスマイナス基底でのパリティチェックだ。どちらの場合も
stabilizerジェネレーターが可換であるため、有効なスタビライザーcodeであることがすぐに分かる。これらは最小
生成集合であり、code空間は非自明だとすでに知っている。また、-1×恒等演算子を
生成できないことも明らかに見て取れる。そして、9 qubit Shoreコードがある。これもスタビライザーcodeだ。
stabilizerジェネレーターで表現されており、この場合は基本的に3ビット
繰り返しcodeが3つのコピーになっている。3つのqubitブロックそれぞれに1つずつ、そして最後の2つのstabilizerジェネレーターがある。
これらの形は前のレッスンで位相フリップを検出するために見たcircuitに似ている。この
codeにおける最後の2つのstabilizerジェネレーターを考える別の方法は、それらが
位相フリップ用の3ビット繰り返しcodeとまったく同じ形をしているが、xをXXXに置き換えているということだ。その理由は
XXXが3ビット繰り返しcodeを使ってエンコードされた論理qubitへのX演算に対応するからだ。しかし
これは余談であり、今は気にする必要はない。まだ不明な点があるかもしれないので、次にいくつか
例を追加で見ていくが、その前に、スタビライザーcodeを記述する際にテンソル積記号をよく省略することを述べておく。読みやすくなるからだ。
これらのcodeをテンソル積記号なしで書くとこのようになる。
もちろんこれらはテンソル積であって、通常の行列積ではない。例えば、テンソル積記号を省いているだけで、
記述がすっきりしてパターンが明確になるようにしている。もう一つ例を紹介する。
7 qubit Steaneコードと呼ばれるもので、かなり注目すべき特徴がある。このユニットの残りのレッスンで
折に触れて戻ってくることになるが、今のところはそれが有効なスタビライザー
codeであることを確認するだけでよい。特に、最初の3つのstabilizerジェネレーターはZが
それ自体と、恒等演算はすべてと可換で、最後の3つも同様だ。残るのは
Z stabilizer generatorの1つとX stabilizer generatorの1つを取った場合に可換かどうかを確認することだ
9通りのペアリングをすべて確認するのは十分簡単で、これらすべての場合において必ず
XとZが同じ位置で偶数回一致することになる。つまり2つのgeneratorは可換になる
xxとZZが可換なのと同じように。これは最小生成集合であり、非自明なcode spaceを持つが
このビデオではそれを論証しようとは思わない。気が向いたら自分で考えてみてほしい。7 qubit Steaneコードは
9 qubit Shorコードと似ていて、1つのqubitをエンコードし、1つのqubitの任意のエラーを訂正できるが、必要なのは
9つではなく7つのqubitだけだ。ただしこれが、1つのqubitをエンコードして任意のエラーを
訂正するエラー訂正コードに必要な最小のqubit数というわけではない。こちらはstabilizer codeで
通常は5 qubit codeと呼ばれ、1つのqubitをエンコードして任意の1 qubitエラーを訂正できる
そして5がこれを実現できる最小のqubit数だ。こちらはもう一つの
stabilizer codeの例だが、code spaceが
1次元であるという意味では、厳密にはコードとは言えない。具体的にはこのコードのcode spaceは、ebitが張る空間、つまり
ベル状態だ。なのでこのコードを使って実際にqubitをエンコードすることはできないが、それでも有効なstabilizer codeで
code spaceがたまたま1次元になっている。GHz状態に対して同様のことをすることも可能だ
これらがstabilizer codeの例で、次のレッスンでは無限に多くの例を見ることになる
次のレッスンで。stabilizer codeが与えられたとき、それについて問いたくなる自然な疑問は
おそらく最初に思い浮かぶ問いとして、何個のqubitをエンコードできるかということだ。その問いには非常に単純な
答えがある。それを説明するために、考えるstabilizer codeについて正確にしておこう。n qubitの
stabilizer generator P1からPrがあり、先ほど述べた3つの要件を満たすとする。つまり
stabilizer generatorはすべて互いに可換で、最小生成集合であるため、generatorを1つ取り除いても同じ
stabilizerにはならない。そしてcode space内に少なくとも1つの非ゼロベクトルが存在する
画面に示された定理が示すように、stabilizer codeのcode spaceは必ず
次元2のn-r乗を持つ。別の言い方をすると、このコードを使ってn
マイナスr個のqubitをエンコードできる。直感的に言えば、エンコードにはn個のqubitがあり、各
stabilizer generatorはエンコードできるqubitの数を1つ減らす効果がある
この定理はそれほど難しくなく、すぐに証明を示すが、まず
いくつかの例を見ていこう。まず通常の3ビット反復コードから始める。エンコードには3つのqubitがあるので
nは3に等しく、R=2のstabilizer generatorがある。したがって1つの
qubitをエンコードできる。これはどのエラーが検出・訂正できるかとは別の話だ
それは別の問題で、これはcode spaceの次元に関する話だ
別の例として5 qubit codeを考えよう。5つのqubitと4つの
stabilizer generatorがあるので、再びcode spaceの次元は2となり、このコードを使って1つのqubitをエンコードできる
もう一つ例を挙げよう。ebit stabilizer codeでは2つのqubitと2つのstabilizer generatorがあるので
code spaceは1次元で、先ほど述べたように、ベル状態が張る空間だ
1つ以上のqubitをエンコードできるコードを含め、例はこれからも見ていくが、今は
定理をどう証明するか見てみよう。まず最初に観察すべきことは、stabilizer
generatorが可換で最小生成集合を形成し、すべてのポーリ演算がその逆演算でもあるため、stabilizer内の各
要素は、各stabilizer generator
PkをAk乗に累乗し、その結果を掛け合わせる積として一意に表せる。ここで各Akは0か1だ
別の言い方をすれば、stabilizer generatorのサブセットをいくつか掛け合わせることでstabilizerのすべての要素が得られ
異なるサブセットから同じstabilizer要素が得られることはない。そしてこれが意味することの1つは
n qubit恒等演算をこの形で表す唯一の方法は、すべての冪を
0にすることだ。次に、各kについて1からRまで、Pkのプラスワインgenspaceへの射影をπkと定義しよう
この射影には単純な式がある。n qubit上の恒等演算とPkを平均すれば、+1固有値はそのままで
-1固有値はすべて0に移る。
さて、code spaceはすべてのstabilizer generatorに同時に+1固有ベクトルとなるすべてのベクトルの集合として定義される
stabilizer generatorが可換であるので、射影も可換でなければならず、そのことが
これらの射影の積もまた射影であることを意味する。特にそれは個々の射影が射影する
部分空間の交差への射影であり、言い換えればcode spaceへの射影だ
この積を展開すると、stabilizerのすべての
要素の平均が得られる。最後に、任意の部分空間の次元は
その部分空間への射影のトレースに等しいので、code spaceの次元はstabilizerの要素に対するトレースの平均だとわかる
ただし、n qubit恒等演算を除くstabilizerのすべての要素のトレースは
ゼロでなければならない。3つの非恒等ポーリ行列はすべてトレースがゼロだからだ。n qubit恒等演算の
トレースは2のn乗なので、code spaceの次元は2のn-r乗であることがわかり、定理が証明された
次は、stabilizer codeを使ってqubitをエンコードする方法について少し述べる。そのためにまず
Clifford演算を導入する必要がある。Clifford演算とは、任意の数の
qubitに対するユニタリ演算で、限られたgateのセット、すなわちHadamard gate、S gate
およびcontrolled-NOT gateを持つquantum circuitで実装できる。T gateは含まれておらず、Toffoli gateやFredkin
gateも含まれていない。そしてそれらのgateがこのリストに含まれていないだけでなく、実はそれらのgateを実装することは不可能だ
ここに列挙されているものを使っているので、Clifford演算ではない。一方、poly演算は
Clifford演算であり、具体的にはHadamardとS gateの列を使って実装できる
なのでClifford演算を定義するシンプルな方法だが、なぜそう定義されるのかや
このgate群の何が特別なのかは説明していない。Clifford演算がこのように定義される本当の理由はこうだ
global phaseを除くと、n qubit Clifford演算とは共役によってpoly演算を
常にpoly演算へ変換するユニタリ演算に他ならない。より正確に言うと、n bit
ユニタリ演算Uがglobal phase因子を除いてClifford演算であるのは、すべてのn qubit poly
演算をUで共役したとき、プラスまたはマイナス1倍の何らかの（別の可能性もある）n
qubit poly演算が得られる場合に限る。この性質はHadamard gate、S
gate、CNOT gateについて簡単に確認できる。したがってこれらのgateから構成されるcircuitでも必然的に成り立つ。難しいのは逆方向を証明することで、
それは特定のn bit ユニタリ演算Uがこの
性質を満たすなら、global phaseを除いてHadamard、S、CNOT
gateだけで実装できるはずだということだ。その含意の証明はここでは省くが、事実であり、興味があれば
調べてみるといい。Clifford演算は量子計算に対してuniversalではない。つまりHadamardとCNOT gateだけでは任意の
量子計算を実行できない。実際、nを固定すると、n qubit Clifford演算は有限個しか存在しないため、
これは演算の離散的な集合であり、
universalなquantum gate集合とは異なり、任意のユニタリ演算を任意の精度で近似することはできない。さらに
標準基底状態にClifford演算を適用し、標準基底測定を行うだけでは、
古典アルゴリズムの範囲を超えた計算は行えない。なぜならこの形式の計算は効率的に古典シミュレートできるからだ
この事実はGottesman-Knillの定理として知られており、その標準的な証明はある意味では
stabilizer形式主義に基づいている。具体的には、共役によってClifford演算がpoly演算をどう変換するかを追跡することで
効率的に行うことができ、そこから計算が
qubitに対して何をするかを推論できる。ではこれはstabilizer符号とどんな関係があるのか。stabilizer符号は
特定の次元のcode spaceを与え、そのcode spaceの使い方は自由に選択できる。つまり特定の方法でqubitをそのspaceに
符号化することを強制されるわけではないが、Clifford演算を使ってエンコーダを形成することは常に可能だ
これは便利だ。なぜならClifford演算は任意のユニタリ演算と比べて比較的シンプルだからだ
実装を最適化する方法があり、それはGottesman-Knill
の定理の証明と同様の方向で機能する。その結果、実装するcircuitはそれほど
大きくなる必要はない。特に、Clifford演算を使ったエンコーディングは常にgate数がほぼ二次を下回る数で実行できる
これはすべてのClifford演算に当てはまる事実だからだ。つまり要点としては、任意のstabilizer符号に対して、
その符号を使ってqubitを効率的にエンコードすることは常に可能であり、Clifford演算を理解するのに役立つ数学的ツールがこの
プロセスに役立つ。例えば、7 qubit Steane符号のエンコーダを示す。これはClifford演算であり、実は
このエンコーダにはS gateすら不要だ。一般的なstabilizer符号でのエラー検出は以下のように
機能する。前と同様に、n qubitのstabilizer生成元P1からPrがあると仮定し、エンコーディングの仮想的なエラーを表すn qubit poly
演算をEとする。なお、エラーとしてpoly
演算のみを考えているのは、エラーの離散化が9 qubit Shore
符号と同様に任意のstabilizer符号でも機能するからだ。エラーを確認する方法は、stabilizer生成元それぞれを
観測量として測定することだ。stabilizer生成元はR個あるので、各結果はプラス1またはマイナス1、
あるいはプラス1をゼロ、マイナス1を1と対応させるなら二値となる。そしてこのR個の結果が
合わさってsyndrome（シンドローム）を形成する。Rが2に等しい3ビット繰り返し符号で見たのと同じだ
一般に、エラーEの検出に関して3つの場合が考えられる。まず
EがstabilizerにあるケースとはEがstabilizer生成元から生成できる場合、または
より一般的にはEがglobal phaseを除いてstabilizer要素と等価なケースだ
この場合、Eは実際にはエラーではない。なぜならcode spaceにおける影響は、せいぜいglobal phaseを
注入する程度で、それは何の効果もないからだ。だからこの種のエラーについては全く心配不要だ。
非自明な作用があるとしてもそれはcode space外での話であり、
気にする必要はない。もっと懸念すべきは、Eがglobal phaseを除いてもstabilizerになく、かつ
すべてのstabilizer生成元と可換である可能性だ。エラーがstabilizer生成元と
反可換であることが、syndromeのどこかにマイナス1が現れる原因だということを覚えておいてほしい
しかしこの場合はそれが起きない。だからこれはcode space内のベクトルを何らかの
非自明な方法で実際に変えてしまうエラーだ。stabilizerの要素と比例していないことからそれがわかる。しかし
符号にはこのエラーが検出されない。これが悪いケースだ。エンコードした
量子情報を変えている可能性があるのに、符号がそれに気づいていない。例えば3ビット
繰り返し符号ではXXXがこのカテゴリに該当する。最後の可能性はEが
少なくとも一つのstabilizer生成元と反可換であることで、これは符号がこのエラーを検出することを意味する。
syndromeのどこかに少なくとも一つのマイナス1が現れ、何かがおかしいと示されるので、このエラーを何とか訂正しようとすることになる
以上が可能性だ。用語として
stabilizer符号の距離とは、第二のカテゴリに該当するpoly演算の最小重み、
つまりcode spaceを何らかの非自明な方法で変えるが、符号が
検出しないものを指す。そしてstabilizer符号がn[[n,m,d]]符号だという場合、
画面に示すように二重角括弧を使うが、それはエンコーディングがn qubitの長さで
このコードはM個のqubitをエンコードできるから、コードスペースの次元は2のM乗で、距離はDだ。つまりエラーが
論理的なqubitの状態を変えるには、重みがD以上でなければ検出されずに
済まないわけだ。では例として7 qubit Steaneコードを見ていこう。その距離が
何かを調べる。これがこのコードのstabilizerジェネレーターで、距離はすべてのstabilizerジェネレーターと
可換だが、それ自体はstabilizerに含まれず、
stabilizerの要素に比例もしていないようなpauli演算の最小重みだ。このコードの距離は
3だと分かる。その決め方は、まず重みが最大2のpauli演算を考えて、
6つのstabilizerジェネレーター全てと可換になれるのは恒等演算だけだという結論を出す。恒等演算は常にstabilizerの要素だ。
そこで、この演算を構成する非恒等pauliの行列をPとQと呼ぶことにして、
それらが最も左の2つの位置に現れると仮定しよう。これは一つのケースに過ぎず、
これらの非恒等pauli行列が現れうる他の全ての位置も考える必要があるが、議論は基本的に全て同じだ。
仮定により、この演算はすべてのstabilizerジェネレーターと可換だから、
特にこの2つとも可換になる。Qはこれら両方のジェネレーターで恒等行列と並んでいる。
だからこそこの2つを選んだわけで、このエラーの右端5つの位置には恒等行列が来る。よってPはxとz両方と
可換でなければならない。そうでなければこのエラーはこの2つのジェネレーターのどちらかとanticommuteしてしまうからだ。だがxとzの両方と
可換なpauli行列は恒等演算しかない。だからPは恒等でなければならない。それが分かれば
左から2番目の位置にxとzを持つ2つのstabilizerジェネレーターをさらに選んで、
Qについても同様の結論が出せる。つまり重みが最大2のエラーがこのコードで検出されずに通り抜ける方法はない。
ただし恒等演算の場合は別で、それはstabilizerに含まれるから実際にはエラーではない。
一方、全6つのstabilizerジェネレーターと可換だが
stabilizerの要素に比例しない重み3のpauli演算は存在する。
こちらに2つの例を示す。よってこのコードの距離は3だと結論できる。
このレッスンで最後に扱うのは、stabilizerコードのエラー訂正だ。
いつも通り、コードはnビットのstabilizerジェネレーターで指定されていると仮定する。
P1からPnまで。まず起こりうる全てのエラーについて少し考えてみよう。
シンドロームは2のr乗通り存在し、レッスンの前半で述べたように、これらのシンドロームは全ての
nqubitのpauli演算を等しいサイズのグループに分類する。つまり各グループには4のN乗を2のr乗で割った数のpauli演算が入る。
特定のシンドロームが観測されたとき、4のN乗を2のr乗で割った
エラーのうちどれが原因かは分からない。ただし少し過剰計上している部分もある。これらの
エラーのいくつかはコードスペースへの効果が全く同じだからだ。特に、エラーEがあって、それにstabilizerの任意の
要素sを掛けると、コードスペースに対してEと全く同じ効果を持つ別のエラーが得られる。
これらは等価なエラーだ。stabilizerには2のr乗個の要素があり、これを考慮すると、
各シンドロームに対して、そのシンドロームを引き起こした可能性のある等価なエラークラスが4のN-r乗個あることが分かる。
つまり、rがnに等しい場合（その場合は1次元のコードスペースとなり
qubitをエンコードできない）を除き、検出できる全てのエラーを訂正することは不可能だ。代わりに
各シンドロームに対して1つの訂正演算を選び、1クラスの等価なエラーだけを訂正することを目指す。
では各シンドロームに対してどんな訂正を行うべきか？自然な戦略は、
測定されたシンドロームを引き起こす最小重みのpauli演算を選ぶことだ。重みの小さいpauli演算の方が
そのシンドロームの説明としてより尤もらしいという考えに基づいている。ただしこれは
一部のノイズモデルでは成り立たない場合もあり、もう一つの自然な戦略はそのシンドロームを引き起こす最も尤もらしいエラーを何らかの方法で計算することだ。
ただし今は、シンドロームを引き起こす最小重みのpauli演算を選ぶことでエラーを訂正しようとする戦略だけを考える。
距離Dのstabilizerコードでは、この戦略によって重みがDの半分より真に小さいエラーを
常に訂正できる。言い換えると重みが(D-1)/2以下のエラーだ。なぜそうなるかを簡単に説明しよう。
これは例えば7 qubit Steaneコードが任意の重み1のpauli errorを訂正できることを示す。そしてエラーの離散化により、
9 qubit Shoreコードと同様に、Steaneコードも1つのqubit上の任意のエラーを訂正できるということになる。
では仕組みを説明しよう。この円がエラーが起きていないことを示す全プラス1シンドロームをもたらす全てのpauli演算を表していると考えよう。
これらの演算の中には、stabilizerの要素、正確にはstabilizerの要素に比例する演算が含まれる。
また、コードスペースを何らかの形で変えるが、
コードで検出されない非自明なエラーも含まれる。距離の定義から、このカテゴリの全てのpauli演算は重みが少なくとも
D以上でなければならない。DはこれらのPauli演算の最小重みとして定義されるからだ。他にも
別のシンドロームを引き起こすpauli演算があり、必要ならそれぞれのシンドロームを順に考えることもできるが、ここでは
あるシンドロームsが現れたと想像しよう。次に、eがこの
カテゴリに属するエラーで、重みが距離Dの半分より真に小さいとする。このeが
この円の中で最小重みのpauli演算であるとは限らない。だからCをこの集合の中の最小重みの演算（同じ重みが複数ある場合はそのうちの一つ）とする。
つまりcはeと等しいかもしれないし、そうでないかもしれない。しかしCは
最小重みだから、CもこのSETに含まれる最小重みの演算なので、eの重みより大きくはなれない。
よって訂正演算Cの重みは距離Dの半分より真に
小さい。ではエラーeが発生した後の状態にこの訂正Cを適用すると何が起きるか？
得られる状態はC×eを元のエンコーディングに掛けたものだ。まずエラーEを掛けて、
次に訂正のためCを掛けるからだ。この積は
元のエンコーディングにEを掛けてからCを掛けて訂正しようとしたもので、この積は
スタビライザーの要素、またはスタビライザーの要素に比例するものだ。その理由はこうだ——まず、eとCが同じ
シンドロームを与えるからだ。C * eは全て+1のシンドロームを与えなければならない——それは特定の
スタビライザー生成元に対して、cとeが両方ともその生成元と可換であるか、両方とも反可換でなければならないからだ。同じでなければならないのは
シンドロームが同じだからだ。そしてそれをほんの少し考えると、c * eは
全てのスタビライザー生成元と可換でなければならないことが分かる。そして最終的にC * eは
スタビライザーの中に収まらなければならない——なぜならそのウェイトはcとeのウェイトの和より大きくなれないからだ。つまりそのウェイトは
Dより厳密に小さい。これは、eに続いてCを適用してもcode spaceに何もしないため、eを正しく訂正できることを意味する。
素晴らしいことだ。しかし問題がひとつある——stabilizer
codesの一般的な場合、与えられたシンドロームを引き起こす最小ウェイト操作を計算するのは計算量的に難しい問題だ。
実際、これは古典的なcodesにも当てはまる——この文脈では、stabilizer codesとして考えられる
スタビライザーのテンソル因子として単位行列とpauli行列のみが現れるものだ。
だからencoding stepとは違い、今回はClifford演算が助けにならない。唯一合理的な
解決策は、効率的に良い訂正を計算できる特定のcodesを選ぶことだ。そのためのレシピはない。
簡単に言えば、このようなstabilizer codesを考案することは、量子Code設計の芸術の一部だ。
このレッスンを終えるのに良い場所だ。次のレッスンにも参加してほしい。
次のレッスンでは、量子Code設計の芸術を見事な形で示すcodesを含む、具体的な量子Code構成を見ていく。
それではまた。